nine point one percent is the june 2022
cpi data uh you say 11 explain the
difference
yeah so uh if you're looking on a
year-over-year rate of change basis so
like june of 2012 uh the taking of the
percentage change from june of 21 you'd
get wind up at 9.1 percent but the more
concerning issue is that we continue to
accelerate on a trending basis so
looking at on a three-month annualized
percentage change basis uh we actually
came in at 10.6
so the time series continues to move
away from the fed's target on pushing us
into a direction of more and more uh
tightening um this report was a disaster
across the board from the perspective of
anybody who is anticipating on inflation
a returning back towards chin on any
reasonable time frame or b anticipating
a sort of uh what we've been talking
about on the program or federal reserve
ambulance sirens anytime soon so when
you see that why do they use the uh
9.1 percent the 12-month year-over-year
versus the three-month uh annualized is
it because the 12-month looks better or
is there some other argument
well no the so it's traditionally how
you want to calculate um in a sort of
time series for the most part um you
know particularly inflation you want to
look at it on a 12 year-over-year basis
you know it kind of takes removes all
the seasonality that tends to be
associated with different cycles in the
economy housing consumer cycles et
cetera et cetera and so that's the
cleanest read on a time series um you
know for something like inflation the
problem is for covet we've had so many
fits and starts as it relates to the
different variants and the proliferation
they're in that it's been ver the time
series on a year over year rate of
change basis has been noisy and to a
degree uh these inflation statistics are
being flattered by some of the um sort
of advent of delta that we saw kind of
uh the beginning of delta that we saw in
the summer of last year but again that's
not the issue the issue is that it
actually is accelerating sequentially
now if you look at it over the last
three months and annualize that
percentage change inflation on the
headline basis is coming in at 10.6
percent uh that's the fastest number
we've seen in a few months but more
importantly things like core inflation
re-accelerating to you know where we at
uh six point or seven point seven
percent on a three-month annualized
basis and my two favorite statistics
something we've been talking about
literally all year on the program are
median cpi and sticky cpi so median cpi
what's the rate of change of all the
different uh different components of the
entire cpi basket there's hundreds of
components
that is accelerating to 7.4
on a three-month annualized basis which
means the median three-month annualized
rate of change of every single thing in
the inflation basket as it is growing at
a rate of 7.4 percent and then if you
look at isolate the variables that are
most sticky that tend to have to tend to
be less responsive to changes in the
economy that tend to have prices move in
a much more auto correlated gradual
fashion uh that is running at 7.6
on a three-month annualized basis that
is a 40-year high for that particular
time series when you start to look at
this uh we saw the federal reserve in
november and december talk tough in 2022
they started to raise interest rates and
they've gotten more and more aggressive
they claim that they're going to do
quantitative tightening and start
selling assets off their balance sheet
uh while they're doing that and interest
rates are going up inflation is
accelerating as well both on a
year-over-year basis but also this
three-month annualized basis
why is that happening and
does this mean in july we're just
getting a big fat one percent interest
rate hike and they're going to try to
bring the big boy weapons to the war now
yeah so i mean i think one thing that's
uh so yeah to answer your question i
think 100 basis points of a rate hike is
very much on the table for the feds uh
july 27th fomc meeting i think the
bigger issue is do they stay at this
this pace right because right now the
fed is operating currently under a
framework that says our star the neutral
rate of
the neutral um interest rate the
interest rate that you know sort of that
causes the economy to neither accelerate
nor decelerate is somewhere around two
and a half percent at least that's what
powell said their estimates were uh the
committee's estimates were uh going back
to last uh that last fomc meeting on
june 15th uh we might start to get to a
process whereby the fed
looking at the data is sort of saying
hey look our policy is being really
ineffective in terms of moving the
needle on inflation maybe we have to
revise up our expectations of our star
and then we actually have to start
speeding up the pace of tightening
that's something certainly something
that has not happened yet and very much
could happen if inflation continues to
surprise the upside in the coming months
you've got a couple of charts here the
first is u.s headline cpi energy and
agriculture can't crash fast enough
explain why you think that
yeah so we've seen uh so commodity
prices if you look at industrial metals
energy uh agricultural prices energy
prices et cetera are really starting to
decline i mean if you look at it on an
index basis you know industrial metals
are off somewhere around 30 off their
highs agricultural energy around of 20
plus percent off their highs but as you
can see in the food and energy price
inflation you know we accelerated to
12.2 percent on food we declined uh to
35 percent on a three-month annualized
basis for energy but obviously 35
percent is not a a reasonable number if
you're trying to get inflation under
control and that's my point is that it's
going to take time for the moves in
commodity markets to be reflected in
inflation statistics it could take
several months
before those kinds of moves are actually
you know adequately pushing inflation
statistics down so that that's the first
chart that's kind of the first key
takeaway there is that we might have to
go through some more pain over a number
of months before we actually see those
declines reflected in the statistics
when you look at this next chart that we
have here you've got that both goods and
service prices are melting up explain
this
yeah so this is uh goes back to
something we talked about er this winter
we were like hey look there's the the
goods disinflation is likely to become
the driver of of course cpi and for a
moment there it was causing core cpi to
slow because we saw sort of the unline
of supply chain disruptions uh we saw
sort of consumer shift they're
purchasing uh the dominance of the
purchasing from goods to services that's
something that's happened on the first
half of this year as well um if you look
at the sort of the rate of change
between goods and services about a nine
to ten that about a thousand basis
points of a difference between the
growth rate of service consumption and
the growth rate of goods consumption so
that cost for a brief moment in time
core inflationary pressures to back off
because goods was moving down faster
than services was going up well now you
got both of them going up simultaneously
um if you look at it again i mentioned
goods uh goods uh core goods inflation
was at 6.6
core services inflation at eight point
two percent you know those two numbers
are moving away from the actual
year-over-year time series which tells
you that we're still building momentum
uh to the upside and core inflationary
pressures this is exactly what you would
expect inflation is a lagging indicator
to the broader economic cycle and you
typically see core inflationary
pressures peter out last as you head
into uh start and sort of middle parts
of a recession
you've got leading indicators or
rocketing past the moon which is just an
all-time title for a slide what is this
saying
thank you just to borrow some uh some
crypto lingos let's let the kids know
that i'm still hip uh anyway um so what
we're showing here in this chart as i
mentioned uh the first set of bars uh
the great by the way to explain these
bars the three the gray bar just shows
the the prior month's three month
annualized rate of change and the blue
bars the most recent months of june um
as you can see we're moving in the wrong
direction if we're trying to get core
pce down right median cpi again the
median of everything in the inflation
basket um is now accelerating at a three
point or at a seven seven point four
percent annualized rate of change that's
the highest three-month range annualized
rate of change we've ever seen immediate
cpi as time series goes back to the
early eighties um if you look at it at
the atlanta fans got a sticky cpi as i
mentioned earlier um that that that
basket is accelerating at seven point
six percent on a three-month annualized
basis the fastest part we've seen since
august of 1982. neither you nor i nor
john were born in august of 1982 so the
feds got a real serious inflation
problem on their hands and what i mean
by that is that those two time series
are very highly correlated to the third
set of bars which is core pce which is
the fed's preferred inflation metric so
that's obviously an issue